i know you
哈啰 各位朋友大家好
我是微提咖啡的Frank
今天喝咖啡了嗎?
好多朋友在家裡沖煮咖啡的時候
常常會遇到品質不夠穩定
無法維持一致性的問題
有時候煮得太苦
有時候煮得太酸
特別是煮得太酸這個問題
很多朋友買了一支非常非常棒的淺焙豆
在沖煮的過程當中
有時候煮到很飽滿的甜感
但是絕大部分的時候
常常獲得的是一杯又酸又澀
或者是又酸又清淡的一杯咖啡
在這過程當中
有沒有朋友想要如何調整
才能夠避免這個問題
享受到一杯原润飽滿
甜感十足的好咖啡呢
今天特別跟朋友分享
當你充足到酸的咖啡的時候
你要如何迅速而正確的
調整你的充足參數
让你立刻回到圆润饱满
甜感十足的风味
咖啡师在处理咖啡豆这个素材的时候
我们一定要考虑到
我们这素材的本质的问题
咖啡豆通常来讲
有非常多不同的一个种类
以及不同的品种
烘焙方式也大意齐趣
我们基本上来讲
以我们常见的类别来分
我们咖啡师拿到咖啡豆
至少会分成两种类别
一个是比较偏浅的烘焙
一个是比较偏深的烘焙
我们要知道浅烘焙的咖啡豆
它因为整个在烘焙过程当中
崩解的有机物质十分有限
导致这整个咖啡豆相对起来
它的密度是比较高的
同时在整个咖啡豆的状态之下
它的细胞孔洞相对是比较小的
在这样的一个条件之下
我们的热水要去萃取这样的咖啡
它的難度相對比較高
因此我們幾乎可以下一個結論
就是淺烘焙的咖啡
它的溶解率是比較低的
相反過來說
深烘焙的咖啡
因為有機物質崩解的較多
以它整個咖啡豆的狀態來講
多孔的狀況
也就是porous的狀況
是比較嚴重的
在這樣的情況之下
熱水非常容易
輕易的進入咖啡粉的本身
去萃取出它想要的物質
我们几乎给下一个结论
生烘焙的咖啡豆
它的萃取率是比较高的
了解到这个问题上面
我们在思考萃取原理的时候
我们不能只有思考萃取原理
我们必须要同步思考
我们所处理的咖啡豆这个素材
它在本质上面来讲
它是属于萃取率高的呢
还是属于萃取率低的
我们在教学上有所谓的英才师教
我们在教学的时候
我们到了解我们的学生程度
是非常專業的呢?
還是剛剛入門的啟蒙者
我們給他的整個的條件就會不一樣
沖煮咖啡也是同樣的道理
熟知沖煮原理的朋友都知道
沖煮的過程當中不是所有物質是一次被萃取出來的它是循序漸進依序被萃取出來的在這個過程當中當我們萃取比較前段的時候這杯咖啡就無可避免的
會比較偏酸鹹這個領域
假如說你在沖煮的過程當中
是把整個沖煮的進程推到比較後段的話
你就無可避免的會充滿了苦味
以及色感
在我們作為一個咖啡師
或者是居家沖煮的咖啡師來說
我們最重要的目的就是趨吉避休
能夠盡可能的落在中間這個令人滿意的範圍
而避開前端的我們稱為萃取不足
以及後端的我們稱之為萃取過度的一個範圍
只要你能夠穩定的維持在中間
我們保證你每一杯咖啡都將是令人愉悅而好喝的好咖啡
好,那回歸我們的重點
當我們沖煮咖啡後
發現我們的咖啡喝起來太酸的時候
究竟應該怎麼辦呢
我們在這邊特別推薦給朋友們三大心法
根據這三大心法
你可以快速迅速的調整你的咖啡的口感
讓你得到一杯更滿意的咖啡
好這三大心法是什麼
第一個我們會建議你調整水分比
什麼意思呢
在我們的沖煮的過程當中
我們剛剛提到萃取的進程
萃取的前段它會比較偏酸
中間它是一個酸甜苦適中的
後段的話它是比較偏苦澀
在我們手沖的過程
我們的濾杯盛裝著我們咖啡粉
我們注入的水量
就可以把它比擰成我們萃取的進程
水量越少就是越前端
水量越多就是越後端
用這樣的一個比例來講的話
我們就非常容易去調整
我們沖煮上面的條件了
舉例來講
假如當我們覺得咖啡喝起來比較酸的時候
它可能代表我們充足的水量稍微嫌少了一點
在這個過程當中
只要稍微增加你的水量
也就是調整一下水分比
你就可以更貼近你所需要的
至終的這個黃金比例的區域
調整水分比上
朋友們有一點特別要注意的
就是我們還要考慮到
這整體咖啡喝起來的濃度如何
我們建議的水分比的區間
大概會是在1比15到1比18之間
假如说你目前充足的情况之下
已经是在1比18左右了
那我们则不建议你再调高你的水分比
这样子的话
你会得到一个非常稀薄
并且浓度太低的一杯咖啡
反过来说
假如你目前的水分比
刚好是落在13、14
或者是14、15的情况之下
我建议你当你喝到酸的时候
直觉性的
你只要再增加你充足的水量
你应该就可以获得一杯
好喝甜感十足的咖啡了
第二个部分会建议朋友们调整的呢
就是我们咖啡粉与水接触的时间
在我们的冲泡咖啡的过程当中
咖啡粉跟水接触时间越长
我们的萃取就可以萃取到越厚段
咖啡粉跟水接触时间越短
我们萃取就会相对的越前段
在我们调节过粉水比后
还是没有办法达到我们的诉求的情况之下
第二件事我们要做的
就是調整我們咖啡粉跟水接觸的時間
我們要怎麼調整呢?
我們在手沖這個手法裡面
我們咖啡師可以做的方式
就是改變你注水的頻率
這是什麼意思呢?
在沖煮的過程當中扣掉第一段預浸之後後面的總水量我們通常來講都會分成二到三次來去做注水每一次注水的過程當中我們都希望每一次注完水
它要濾滴完之後再注下一輪的水
濾滴完之後再注下一輪的水
這樣子可以保持我們整個沖煮上面的一致性
以及它非常強的一個穩定性
我們要如何能夠增加咖啡粉與水接觸的時間呢
非常簡單
我們原本假如把水量分成兩個段落去萃取的話
我們則建議你可以從兩個段增加到三段
假如原本是三段的話
我們可以建議你從三段可以增加到四段
分的段數越多
你的總時間就勢必會越長
總時間越長
你所萃取出來的物質也無可避免會更多
你的萃取率將可以有效的往後段去做推移
這杯咖啡喝起來或許太酸
在萃取進程當中太偏前面
我們透過增加充足時間
我們就可以有效的把我們萃取進程往後移一些
讓你萃取出無與倫比的甜感
第三個部分假如你調了水分比
而且調節了咖啡粉跟水接觸的時間
還是沒有辦法達到你嚴格的要求的話
第三個我則建議你可以稍微調整我們的眼膜科系度
我們的眼膜科系度越粗的話
水跟咖啡粉接触的总面积上面来讲
相对会比较少
假如我们把它切成非常多
无数的细小的粉末的话
它跟水接触的总面积
会相反的变得相当的大
换句话说
研磨的越细萃取率将会越高
研磨的越粗萃取率相对的越低
在这个过程当中
假如我们现在目前喝到的咖啡是偏酸的
我们希望增加它萃取率的话
请你可以把你的研磨科系度稍微调细一点
只是朋友们要特别注意
当你在调节研磨科系度的时候
一定要注意两件事情
第一件事情
调整研磨科系度
一定要记得预模一份的咖啡豆
植若粉型的磨豆机
就算它不需要用非常多的咖啡豆
你还是需要用两三克的我们的咖啡豆
去稍微的预模一次
才能够把上一轮的残留的咖啡粉
能够把它清除掉
但是假如你是用手摇磨豆剂的话
您就大可不用担心类似这样的问题
它几乎都是直通通的直落粉
几乎没有任何的残粉
并没有所谓的机构的问题
所以都可以不用担心
这是第一件非常重要的一个事情
第二件事情是
当我们调细了眼膜科系度的时候
你除了会增加你的萃取率之外
请你不要忘了
你也會相對的增加它的濃度
而這樣的濃度在你飲用的過程當中
是不是可以接受的
你也要稍微去做一個評估
當然會有些朋友問到
有關於水溫的問題
是不是也應該要做某個程度來調整
那調整了它
是不是就會影響到酸度的表現
答案肯定是的
但是我在這邊有個小小的建議
特別是對居家
或者是剛剛進入手沖領域的朋友來講
我們通常來講是
不建議你去調整水溫的
我們的原因很簡單
沖煮的過程當中要維持一致性
其實相當的困難
我們不建議有太多的元素
同時間去做更動
這樣子的話
會讓你有如大海撈針一樣
很難找到你風味的燈塔
非常容易就迷失了
在這個過程當中
特別是以水溫來講我們一般所謂的水溫應該要多少通常指的是我們充足的起始溫度其實在你起始到最後這段水溫上面來講
我們比較不易掌握
我們只能建議你盡可能在起始溫度上
保持在90到96度之間
找一個適合你風味的起始點
就請你固定下來
可以不需要去做額外的更動
同時你也要特別知道
當我們的水溫低於90度以下
特別是低於88度之下的話
可能對你的酸質溶解也會有一定的局限
過低的水溫對於酸質溶解的效率也會大幅的降低
它會影響到你咖啡的明亮度
一支非常酸香鮮明的一支咖啡
明亮感十足的咖啡
也會因水溫降低而大打折扣
我們覺得你不需要冒這樣的一個風險
因此對居家的朋友來講
我們認為水溫不會是你目前現階段要考慮調整的項目
4.2 蝶子
OK 這樣子酸甜四周
應該可以的
好,那透過以上的分享
朋友們有沒有躍躍欲試
很想趕快拿起家裡的手中器材
來試試看呢
我們剛剛提出一些建議
都是希望朋友們
能夠有效的改善在家裡面
煮不出一杯好咖啡的
一點小小的困擾
我們都希望你在居家當中
買了好的咖啡豆
也能夠呈現出
類似像專業咖啡館
一樣的一個風味
把好咖啡分享出去
是我們為敵一直以來的理念
不但我們這麼做
我们也鼓励朋友们这么做
一旦朋友们学会了好的技巧
跟好的心得
不要忘了
也要把您好的技术
分享给你的亲朋好友
让他们跟你一样
能够享受一杯又一杯的好咖啡
好吗
OK
好
那喜欢我们影片的朋友
记得帮我们按赞分享订阅
并记得开启通知小铃铛哦
謝謝朋友們持續關注微滴咖啡的頻道
您的支持跟鼓勵是我們進步最大的原動力
看到好的影片請不吝幫我們多多的分享
那謝謝大家囉
我們下次再見
掰掰
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive